早速 話が始まりますけど
今日は いろいろ人間がする この予定というか 計画とかね
そういうものについて
一応 人生論を語りたいんです
別に 予定って云々ということではなくて
計画って何なのかということではなくて
そのテーマに基づいて
人生ってどういうものかと
で お釈迦様の初期仏教の話から 説明したいと思います
なんでそういう話になるかというと
一番最初に言いたいところは
やっぱり仏教っていうのは 宗教として見てみるならば
例えばね 神様などをね
信仰する宗教のような場合は
どんな宗教の人々でも
世の中のことはね それほどうまくいくっていうことは 信じてはないし
で その場合は じゃあ神に祈って神に頼っていれば
もう安全だよというふうな立場をとるんですね
あるいは希望通りにいかなかったら
まあいいんじゃないか
それはどういうわけかって知っているのは神様だから
神様の気持ちだから あなた落ち着きなさい というふうな話をして
人々の心を 何といいますか
慰めてくれるんですね
例えば 大変な不幸なことがあっても
なんで私にそんなことになるんでしょうか
私は毎日 欠かさずに祈りしているんではないか といったところで
そんな慌てなくても
それはあなた 毎日 神様にお祈りしているんだから
それは何か神様がお考えになっていらっしゃるでしょうと
ですから 自分でそんなに気にしなくてもいいんではないか というふうに言われると
大体心っていうのは そうでしょうかと
そうですよということで落ち着きますね
それから 他のそんなに 絶対的な神というものは信じてない場合はね
で この厳密に神様を信じる宗教っていうのはいくつかあっても
神は信じてるんだけど
なんかちょっともやもやで はっきりしない人々の場合は
何かお守りとかね
何かに頼って 自分の身の安全
人生の安全というものは図っちゃうんですね
皆様に分かりやすいんだから言いますけど
例えば日本の車だったら
必ず 交通安全のお守り
御札がついてるんですね
それは批判的に言うんではなくて
皆様よく使っているもので
いわゆる絶対的な神というものは もう頑固と信仰している民族ではありません
だから そこら辺にある何かを
その仕事に応じて
もう安全対策としてお守り
御札などを使ったりもします
で 時々この星占いか 八卦占いとかね
何か占ってみてどうでしょうか というふうになってきて
占いはうまく出たんだからとかね
今日は 御籤はもう大吉でしたよとかね
そういう気持ちでも
心の安定を探している場合もありますね
ですから そういうようなことは日常茶飯事で
人類は大体 誰でも多かれ少なかれやっていることで
これはないということは言えないんです
そういうことだから 自分で立て というお釈迦様の教えから
その問題どういうふうにしますか？という
なんで地球上の人類は 誰でも何かに頼っていますかと
例えば共産圏の国々の場合でも
もう完璧に否定していましたからね
そういう神秘宗教などなどはね
インチキということで
それでも一般人の心の中で
ものすごくこの その必然性が湧いてくるんですよ
隠れてでも何かお守りしよう
お祈りしようではないかと
ですから 一旦 共産主義の力が弱くなってくると
ものすごい爆発的に ボンと宗教っていうのは 飛び上がっちゃうんですね
ということは 心の中でずっと この必要ということはあったわけなんです
だから昔からもうあって
今までこの 21世紀になっても
我々の心に 何かに祈りたいと
何かをお守り欲しいという気持ちがあるんですね
ですから それは人類にある 一つの問題なんですね
それどういうことかというと
やっぱり不安なんですよ
いろんなことについて　不安というのは必ずあります
それで何かにチャレンジして
何かをする場合はうまくいくでしょうかと
どうでしょうかという
それも不安なんですけどね
そのことも確実にあるんです
何一つ 物事は これはもう 100%うまくいきますよ という保証っていうのはないんです
ですから そこら辺で もう何かに頼っちゃう ということは出てくるんですね
ですから このお釈迦様が自分の足で立ってなさいとかね
いろんなことに あまり余計なものにね
頼るなよというふうなことは言ってるんだけど
我々の心にはこの不安という問題は 確実にありますよ
商売もうまくいくでしょうか
ないかとかね 健康でいられるかないかとかね
そういうことっていうのは 必ずあります
ですから 最終的な答えとして
お釈迦様が考えたのは この心の不安を
心にある この不安定な状態
それ直しましょうということであって
そうすると どうってことはないと
では そういうことなんですね
だから 必ずあなたの希望通りに
こういう風にすれば 100%うまくいきますよというふうな
この万能薬みたいな方法を教えたわけじゃないんです
例えば神々がいっぱいいて
ABCDとかね  Zまでいるとしたらね
ある人は Aの神様を信仰して
ある人は Bの神様 そこの中で一人が Xでも Yでもいいんだけども
絶対的で 何でも叶えてくれる神様みたいなものがいるならば
みんなそちらに頼ればいいことで
でも 世の中でいろんな神々にみんな頼って お祈りしてはいるんですけど
よく客観的に見ると みんな同じなんですよ
アッラーという神様を信仰しても
ジェホバという神様を信仰しても
そこら辺の他の神様を信仰しても
人生はみんな結局 同じなんですね
成功する人がいて しない人がいる
大変な不幸に遭う人もいて
そうでない人もいるとか
病弱になる人もいて 大変元気でいる人もいるし
これが 宗教あるかないかということに関係なく 普通にあることで
そこでお釈迦様が それは全部なくなって
完璧に物事 100%うまくいく方法
こういう方法があるんだよというふうに言ったならば
それはそれでいいんですけど
そんな方法はおっしゃってないんです
その代わりに おっしゃっているのは
そんなことは放っておいて　世の中のことはね
あなたの心の不安をね
そこは自分で管理できるんだから
そこら辺なんとかしましょうと
そうすると この各個人に どんなものにも立ち向かうというか
その勇気が出てくるんですね
だから失敗は怖いよと
失敗したくないと言っちゃうと
心が弱くなっちゃうんですね
そうすると行動ができなく
失敗したらどうしようか
どうしようかとかね 初心者の車の運転みたいなことで
事故を起こしたらどうしようか
どうしようかと事故を起こしちゃうんですね
もうものすごい心配しすぎて
ですから この そういうことじゃなくて
心が安定しているんだったら
失敗しても成功であっても そんな別に
怖くないという状態でいられるならば
心は安定するんですから
お釈迦様は 特別に心を育てる ということを教えちゃうんですね
ですから ご利益の秘訣ではなくて
安定した 清らかな しっかりした心を育てる方法
で 他の宗教になってくると
心のことも言いますけど
あまり重点はそちらに置かないで
やっぱり 社会で成功することやら ご利益のことを話したりするんですね
そうすると私たちも なるほどすごいと思って
そちらに 食ってかかって 飛びかかっていくんですけど
だからといって そんな100%成功している人っていうのはないんです
そういうとこは基本的にありますので
仏教はそういう いろいろ生きる上で
我々にどのような提案をしているかということを 勉強してみた方がいいと思います
それから 信仰の宗教ではございませんので
実践の宗教ですから 教えているものはコツコツと毎日 実践してみないと
うまく効き目が出てこないんですね
祈りみたいなものがないんだから
ただ仕事をしながら みんなと話しながら
いろんな人生を生きながら
その中で実践できる方法っていうのを 教えているんですよ
例えば人間は 仕事をしなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは 仕事はどのようにすればいいかということであって
仕事をする前に 5分お祈りしなさいということじゃないんです
皆様方 イスラム教の国々に 旅行にいらっしゃるでしょう おそらく
行ってみてください
12時になったら どこにも誰もいないんです
お祈りに行ってるんです
だから突然 もう仕事真っ最中でも 1日 5回やってますから
もうみんな お祈りしてるんですね
面白いことは その国々の飛行機に乗っても
その時 みんな全部 仕事をやめて祈りしようとするんだから
ちょっと冗談じゃないと言いたいとこなんです
もしも じゃあ操縦士も 今お祈りの時間だから
じゃあお祈りしようと
それはだけはもう やめているんです
私は一回見たんだけど
やっぱり中のサービスしているね 方々は
そちらもイスラム教でちゃんと全部 体隠して 女の人々いるんだけど
それはもうやめなさいと
みんなに迷惑だと言って
やめさせたんですけど
同じ宗教同士だからよかったと思いますよ
他の宗教の人では こんなことやったら困ると言っちゃったら
もうどうなることかわからないんです
だからそういうふうな
感情的な何かで みんなを団結させて動かすというのは
仏教はあまりではなくて
全くそれは良くないと
人間というのは集めたら恐ろしい組織で
何するかわからないものだから
そうやってこの何かに
得体の知れない何かに 概念を入れて固めると
いいところよりも 危険の方が多いんですよ
それよりは バラバラで 自分の意見があって
いた方が 害は少ないんですね
例えば誰かを殴りましょうと
3人で話しても 3人も意見バラバラだったら
なかなか団結して拉致できないんですね
何か言っただけで はい やりましょうという状態だったら
これはすごい危険なんです
なぜかというと 人間の心というのは そんな信頼できるものではありません
そういうことで お釈迦様の道っていうのは
仕事をする前に 10分 20分 30分 これこれやりなさいとかね
例えば我々は習慣的に朝やら昼やら 色々お経なんかもやったりはするんですけど
それはもうお釈迦様がした決まりじゃないんです　一つも
そういう形式的な決まり 一つも決めてないんです
出家している人々には厳しく
ものすごい厳密に いっぱい決まりありますけど
それでもこの一日時間なくなるようにとかね
そういうのはないんです
で 月2回ぐらい集まればいいんだと
月2回だから 別にそれは
そこら辺のお坊さんたちに 簡単に集まるし
それで例えば髪の毛を剃らなくちゃいかんということがあるんですね
それにしても お釈迦様は 月1回ぐらいで十分だと
毎日ピカピカと剃らなくちゃいけないってことになっちゃったら
それに毎日かなり儀式的に時間かかっちゃうんです
ですから もういくらか伸びたっていいやと
月というか この
ふた月に1回だと思いますけどね
結構 伸びますよ そうすると　あまり伸びすぎちゃうと格好悪いんだから
この指の2つの節というんですか
その長さ超えちゃうと もう剃りなさいと
だから随分この楽に
出家は修行することだからね
そこら辺に重点を置いて
この形式 しきたり そういうものに人を束縛するということはないんです
でも人間というのは形式やらね
こういう儀式というのはすごい好きだからね
仏教にも テーラワーダ仏教にしても
いろんな儀式とかね 習慣とかはどんどん入ってはいるんで
そういうものには時間は取られてしまうし
仕事を休んできて その儀式をやらなくてはいけないことにも なっちゃったりするしね
そういうことはあるんだけど
それはお釈迦様が決めたものというではありません 一つも
ですから お釈迦様は我々におっしゃっているのは
朝起きて寝るまで 我々は何かしなくてはいけないことであって
それがどのようにすればいいかということですからね
わかりやすくいえば 包丁を使わなくちゃいけない
それで包丁の使い方を教えるだけのことで
それで何か都合が悪いことでもありますかね
我々は包丁を使わなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様が じゃあ包丁の使い方を教えますよと
それはたとえ話で言うんであって
別に経典に包丁の使い方はないんですけど
誤解しないでください
そこである人が 仕事は運転手だと言ったら
ではあなたに 運転の仕方を教えますよと
でお釈迦様は 別に技術を教えるんではなくて
もう 一つありますね 運転するときはどんな心構えでしょうかと
技術は技術の学校で勉強しなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから 決して人生に負担にならないんです
その負担にならない生き方を 教えているんです
そういうことで このテーマも考えた方がいいと思います
それで 予定というものは計画でしょうしね
で なんかわからないんだけど
私たちはずっと 計画なしに 何一つもできないんですね
計画しないできちんと段取りを取らないと
何一つもできない のは人間なんです
だから人間というのは昔から いつでもいろいろ計画を立てるんです
それでしきたりなども生まれてきたのは
その弱みなんです 弱みというならば
弱みかどうか分かりませんけどね
例えば宗教的な習慣でも
夏になってくると いろいろお祭りしなくちゃいけないとかね
お盆ちゃんとやらなくちゃいけないとか
いろいろ習慣が出てくる
そうするともう それに合わせて我々は生き方を変える
だから 諸宗教の中にある いろいろな儀式 儀礼なども
この人間に計画が必要だから 出てきたものなんです
何かセットを決めてあげないと
人間はまとめてくれないんですね
ですから 何かこの枠を 基準を 規則を決めて
置いておくんですね
だから私たち現代人が
作る 立てる計画 いろんなプラン
プランですか いろんなプラン
plansとか 計画とか 予定と
それから 昔から いろんな宗教による儀式 儀礼とは
大して変わりがないんです　同じものなんです
すごい会社の もう管理のレベルの人々がね
会社の経営について いろんな計画を立てる
ものすごい分厚い 文章を作って
今年の計画はこれだよとかね
それはすごく言われて もうすごい研究して
きちんと作った計画ですよとか 会社のためにとか
それと
いつでしたっけ？京都の灯籠流しとかありますね
何月か もう夏になってからやると思いますけどね
その日になったら 灯籠を流しましょうとか
それと違いますか？とか
違わない　同じことなんです
全く同じことで　あれはただ 昔からそういう風に決めてやっただけで
だから そういうふうに決めているんだから
その日にちになってくると
みんなその あれをなんとか作って
川でもう流しちゃうんです
お盆が終わったところで
会社にしても もう作った計画通りに 1月どうしますか
2月どうしますかとかね
その通りに動く だから別に考える必要ないんです
すべて人間というのは 何か決まっておかないと不安で動かない
言うことを聞いてくれない というところがあるんです
だから何か ノルマでもぶん投げらないと
投げてあげないと 社員たちが動いてくれないんです
会社にも社員に あなた方はリラックスして
まあ適当に頑張ってくださいと言っちゃうと
何一つもやってくれない
それで実現できないぐらい
もうものすごい難しい
もう高い数字のノルマなんかつけちゃうんです
いろいろチャートまで作って
今週の売り上げは 誰さん 何さんがどれぐらいですかとかね
そういうふうな 精神的ないじめまでしたりして
それも一つの儀式なんですよ
宗教儀式と同じことで
それで月に一回集めて
今月の成績発表とかになってくると
みんな神経質になって
もう顔を真っ青にして聞いてるんだから 社員たちが
だから宗教儀式と全然変わり違いますかね
同じことです だから
ちゃんとそのしきたり 決まりを守らなくちゃいけないかと思って
一生懸命 苦労して仕事をする
ですから この覚えておいてください
この古くから伝わってくる
このいろんな宗教にある
儀式 儀礼とかね そういうものと 生贄まででもね
そういうものと 我々が現代経済社会でやっている
計画的な生き方とはそんな変わりがない
学校にしても もう何から何まで計画 計画
しきたり 規則で
例えば 日本なのに 日本の会社に行く場合は
西洋人の服を着ていなくちゃいけないんでしょう
ネクタイをつけなくちゃいけないと
それも一つの儀式なんですよ
何でもいいやと思ったら
どうするか分からないんだと　心配だと
それで見てください
結局 このしきたりが優先になって
人間の存在が小さくなる
例えば会社なんかは自分好きな普段着というかね
好きな服を着てくださいと
なかなか会社 それ決められませんね
その意見だけはあったんです
そんなに厳しく 色やらネクタイの色やら 何から何まで決めつけるよりは
それぞれ今 豊かな社会でしょうし
いろんな服もあるでしょうし　ですから 自由に
それなりにおしゃれして来たっていいんじゃないかなという意見はあったんだけど
そのまま 意見のまんまで流産するんです
ちゃんともう元気で そこは一つ 行動にはなってこないんですね
ですから この 一つ決まり決めちゃうと
決まりのために生きているということになっちゃうんです
それはすごい残念なことですけど
危険なことなんです だからそれ宗教に合わせてみると
いろいろ宗教で儀式 しきたり決めちゃうと
人間はどうでもいいことになっちゃって
宗教で決まったものは 実行しなくちゃいけないんだということになっちゃうんですね
それで 人を殺したりというところまでも行っちゃうんですね
だから そこら辺はおかしいんです
計画なしに生きていられないというならば
そこまではいいんですけど
やがて計画が もう神の言葉になってしまって
計画のために生きていなさい ということになっているんですね
だから人間が作った計画が やがて人間を支配する
今 我々はそうやって 計画に支配されて生きているんです
それが仏教的じゃないんです
計画立てるな ということじゃないんです
あの SF 映画など 皆様知ってるでしょう
今 ロボットやらね もういろいろ何でも自動化するんだよと
オートメーションにするんだよと
それで家の仕事やら もう何でもかんでも ロボットを作って
大変優れたコンピューターやら IC を開発して
それで何でもプログラム組まなくても
ロボット 自分のプログラムを自分で組めるようにしようではないか
そういう SF的な話なんですけど
そうするといくつかの映画 出ているでしょう
結局 コンピューターたちが
ロボットたちが人間を抑えて 支配して
もう殺してしまっちゃうと
というアメリカの映画も いくつかありましたからね
やっぱりその 映画を作る人にしても
実際に 世の中でないものは想像できませんから
台本書いた人やら スクリプトを書いた人々やら
世界を見て
この西洋の世界 アメリカの世界を見たら
結局 計画のために生きているんではないかと
人間のためにコンピューターを作ったんだけど
次にコンピューターのために 人間が変えなくちゃいけないんで
自分を変えなくちゃいけないんですね
だから そういうふうなことになって
大事な これ人間が大事なんですけど
そこを忘れてしまうんですね
だから今の世界を見たら
経済発展とかなんとか言いながら
経済発展が大事なことであって
人間はどうでもいいと
決まり守ることは大事であって
この守られる側の苦しみは
そんなことはもう関係ないんだと
だから 落ちこぼれやら もういっぱい出てくるんですね
そうすると人間 逆にまた不幸になっちゃうんですね
だからこの計画性の出てくる 最初に出てくる問題はそれなんです
人間が人間のために作ったものは
人間をいじめる 支配するものになってくるんです
犬が人間に番犬頼むような
ちゃんと守ってくれと
俺が寝るんだぞと という状態になっているんです
だから犬に飼われている状態になっているんですね
犬を飼って番犬にする状態で始めたんだけど
逆に犬に飼われている
実際にはありますからね
犬を飼ったら
犬によって全部自分の人生設計を変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますからね
仏教というのは智慧の教えだから
これは知的な生き方ではないんです
やっぱり自分の立場を
自分の幸せというのは 失ってはいけないんです
たとえ動物飼ってもいいんだけど
だからといって動物のレベルまで
人間の人格まで落とさなくちゃいけないと言ったら
これはあまりにも残酷なおかしいことなんです
ですから この私は人間で
一匹の動物も飼ってあげるんだよと
自分の幸せ 自分の生活
自分の立場っていうのはやっぱり
守りながら やらなくちゃいけないことなんですけど
だから そこら辺気をつけましょうと
計画立てることをやめましょうと言っても
これは人間には無理なんです
計画立てないでやるということは 無理なんです
じゃあ 明日朝早く出かけましょうと
5人ぐらいで話してみてください
じゃあ明日早く なんとか場所で 駅の前の喫茶店で会いましょうと
何時に集まると思いますか？
集まりませんよ
だから9時半と言わないと
あるいは10時と言わないと
じゃあ明日 10時に駅の前の喫茶店で集合して
次の何とかしよう という風にぎっしりとしておかないと
じゃあ早くからやりましょうと言っても 絶対無理でしょう
それぐらいのことは誰でもわかってます
それが人間なんです だから計画立てること
予定を作ることは もう悲しいことで
もうどうにもならんことなんですね
ですから この計画を立てるとうまくいく
ですから 何でも計画した方が悪くないんです
何から何まで ぎっしりと
でも そちらへ出てくる危険というのは
何から何まで 計画を立てると
自分が 計画のために生きている奴隷になっちゃうんです
自分の自由と 心の安らぎ
楽しみというのは 全部消えちゃう
それで自分が じゃあ私は毎日もう
今日から6時に起きますと 自分でちゃんと計画を立てる
そこである日 6時に起きられなくなっちゃうと
大変 その人が自分を責めたりする
それから 次から次へともう狂ってしまう
なんかすごい悪いことをしたような感じにもなる
それはもう計画に支配されている状態なんですね
とにかく早く起きましょうと思ったら
一度もまた実行しない
やっぱり 6時に起きましょうというふうに決めなきゃ起きられませんし
とにかく早く起きます と言ったら9時になる可能性もありますし
それでちゃんと 6時に起きるぞと計画されたところで
ある日なんとかできなかったならば
ものすごく自分を責めたりして ショックを受けたりするだけではなくて
その日の次の計画から もう全部狂ってしまう というのは人間の生き方なんです
それは 動物たちの生き方と比べてみてください
何の計画もないんだけど
きちんとその日で その日でやらなくちゃいけないことは すごくうまくやるでしょう
で 動物たちが 例えば交尾をして子どもを作ると
うまく季節に合わせてあって
その動物に 子どもの頃はいっぱい餌がある時期に合わせて ちゃんと産むんだからね
そうすると親たちが きちんとあっちこっち行って餌を持ってきて
持ってきて 自分の子どもたちに食べさせて大きくする
誰も教えてないんです
この時間になって この時期で
例えば冬 交尾する動物いるんですね
それもちょうど春になってきていると
もう子どもを産むような計算で よくやってます
このもう動物も時々集めて会議とかやりますけどね
やりますよ よく私は見るのはカラスなんですけど
ちゃんと定期的に会議やるんです
よく見ているんですけど
聞こえますけど 何喋ってるかわかりませんけど
とにかくそれぞれ みんなもうよく喋ります
喋ってきちんと時間になってくると みんな解散しますね
あまり喧嘩とかは見えませんけどね
そこでうまく集まること
その決まった場所で うまく集まって
じーっと座っているカラスもいるし
よくしゃべるカラスもいるし
親分で かなり大きい声でみんなにしゃべるカラスもいるし
それで あっちはもう大きくしゃべるんだけど
こそこそ 2人 3匹ぐらい
3羽ぐらい 別に喋ってる時もちょくちょく見えますけどね
それで終わったら みんなあまり長い時間もやりません
大体 人間の時間で言えば 1時間以内に終わりますけどね
だから私はこれ監視して見てみたんだけど
ちゃんと定期的にやってます
だから他の動物もそういうふうな
いろいろ 家族制度がある動物はいるしね
社会制度ある動物もいるしね
そちらでは別に決まった計画はないんだけど
やっぱり計画通りにやってますね
だから動物の世界では
計画に支配されているかどうかっていうことはちょっとわからないんです
じゃないと思いますけど 楽にいるんだからね
ですから 人間にとっては それはもう大変 無理な話で
我々はもうなんとか考えて 計画立てなくてはいけないんですね
だから我々は作る計画っていうのは
あくまでもこの 自然発生じゃないんだから
６時に起きますということは
自然的な考え方じゃないんです
これは時計という機械
から考えるものなんですよ
自然の中だったら 大体 人間というのは
この自然にこの太陽が出てくる
そこそこでもう目が覚めるんです
太陽が出てくる その時間になってくると
もうだいたい目が覚めます
ですから 冬と夏は自然的に言えば違うんですよ
冬だったら人間っていうのは 7時まででも寝ている可能性あります
で 皆さんは経験あるでしょう
夏になってくると あまりにも早く目が覚めちゃって
夜も寝れなくて ああ 大変だ
大変だ 泣いてるでしょうね
あれは泣くことじゃなくて
あれは自然なんですけど
夏ぐらいになってくると
もう7時になっても もうすごい明るいし
もう元気で活発的で活動したいんですよ
そこで 夜ちょこっと寝ただけでまた目が覚める
目が覚めて外を見てください
ちゃんともう太陽が出ているんだから
これで人間っていうのは
この人工的な計画の中にいるんだから
昨日大変困ったもんだ
なんでしょうか 3時半で目が覚めてなかなか寝られなくなった
3時半でも4時になってくると もう光が見えてくるんだから
ちょうど時間に目が覚めているはずなんですけど
光がある時は働けっていうのは自然の決まりで
だからちゃんと自然の計画の通りに行ってますけど
私たちはそれに逆らってるんですね
それで光が当たらないようにきついカーテンなんかつけて
雨戸もつけちゃって もう真っ暗にして 強引に変えてもう寝る
だからそういうふうに我々は機械に支配されていることになっているんですね
だから人間の計画っていうのは
ものすごい狂いやすい
もうほとんど狂ってしまっちゃうし
それで計画を守ることで
もう大変で もう健康も損なうわ
もういろいろ幸せを 破壊しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 幸せのために作った計画で 幸せを破壊するということになるんです
それは一つ 仏教の基本的な論理なんです
幸福を目指す人々が
幸福を壊す方法しか思い出せないんだ
それで幸福を壊す方法
幸福を目指す方法だと勘違いして頑張っている
それで結果としては 当然の結果として大変 不幸に
苦しみになってしまいますよ
それである中部経典にあるところなんですけど
人間がカーマ(kāma) 欲というものあるんですね
欲が激しくあるんです
欲っていろいろありましてね
財産欲しいやらね
家族が欲しいとかね 子供が欲しいとか
そういう欲で生きてます
ですから欲があるんだから
普通どんな人でも 食べて楽に生きるためには
お金やら財産欲しい 幸せ 生きるために
それで家族も欲しいと
それで家族やら全部作る
それからお金 儲からなくちゃいけないでしょう
そういうことで この経典にあるのは
それで人々が 給料がいいと思って
例えば軍隊に入ると 昔の軍隊というのはかなり厳しいもんでしたからね
行って いろんな人々と戦うんだと
戦争に行くんだと 行って槍にも刺されるわ
刀で切られるわ 象に踏まれるわ
それで敵軍が来ると あの
いろいろ なんて昔よくやったみたいですね
この油とかね もう沸騰するんですね
して この塀の上なんか置いといて
軍隊来ると ボーンともうかけちゃうんです
だから そういう戦争術でしたからね
で そういうものを もう体にかけちゃうし
それで火傷をするし
矢で撃つんだけど 矢の先はもう火をつけているし
そうすると全部 燃えちゃうしね
それでものすごい残酷に 苦しみを味わって死んでしまう
何のためかというと 家族を守るために行って
家族を養うために行って
結局 自分まで苦しんで 死んでしまうのではないかと
そこで欲があるんだから
母が父と喧嘩するんだと
母と子供は喧嘩するんだと
父と子供が喧嘩するんだと
親戚同士でも喧嘩するんだと
財産のために 豊かになるために
幸せになるために やっていることなんですね
それでなれないのは当たり前なんだよ
やってしまっちゃうんです
ですから 幸せになりたいという気持ちがあるんだけど
例えば 私は全部の財産を自分で取りたいと ある人が思う
自分が幸せになるためなんですね
それで兄弟ともう戦うんです
敵に回ってずっと戦う
兄弟もまた戦うと それで財産はもう
法律でちゃんと 五分五分に分けることになっても
もう半分ぐらい もう裁判に行ってるんです
残る半分を分けてもらわないと
最初からもう分けてもらった方が 何のこともないんですけどね
それで分けられないものについては もう裁判にするとか
そうやって欲があって 幸せになりたいということがあって
結局 持っているものを失ってしまうというのは人間の生き方ですよと
だからこの計画の世界についても
同じことで 幸せになろうと思って計画を立てて
それでもって幸せを失う
ということが 世の中にある事実なんです
では 私たちはどうすればいいか ということになります
まず最初に言ってましたから
この計画を立てるということ自体が 別にもう
悪いわけじゃないんですね
いわゆる悪いと言っても
悪いかいいかではなくて なんか避けられない
何か避けられないことなんですね
だからといって計画自体が そんなにすごいものではありません
それが必要である 一つの 人間の道具に過ぎないんですね
その価値が大事なんですね
我々は計画に すごい価値を入れて
人間の価値を減らしちゃうんですね
生きるということ 楽にいるんだという価値を もう減らしちゃうんですね
そこら辺 気をつけてみれば 簡単に
学校の決まりは何のためにありますか？といつでも考えなくちゃいけない
それはすごい簡単に忘れる
決まり守れと
そして子供たちが逆に 何のためにある決まりか聞いたら
管理できない子供たちだと
問題児たちだと言って
もうカウンセラーのところに運ぼうとする
どちらが行くべきかといえば
やっぱり 管理する側が行くべきだと思いますけど
国の憲法から始めて 家族の中で 母親が決める決まりまで
全てもう計画なんですけど
全て何のためということ
それがすごく大事なんです
それをまず覚えておくこと
それから いつでもそれを思い出すこと
決まりだから守れ ということじゃないんです
なぜその決まりを作ったんでしょうかと
ですから 計画自体っていうのは
そういう目的がなくなっちゃうと
もう守る必要はなくなっちゃうんです
それじゃなくて もう50年前に決めた決まりでも
厳密に守ろう 守ろうとして
また不幸になるということは
あんまりこの説法で 私はもう 言えない例いっぱいありますけどね
日本の社会を見ても
もういい加減やめた方がいいんじゃないかなと この法律はとかね
もうよくよく感じるものあるんですけど
それでも頑固に守るぞと　何のためですか？と
聞きたいところはいろいろあるんです
なかなか 皆様方は気づかないみたいですけどね
例えば 子供があっちこっち行って
いろいろ なんか悪いことをして
見つかったとしますね
それで 両親が子供に厳しい決まりを作る
外へどこへ行って遊んでも
きちんと 6時に家に帰らなくちゃいけないんだと
それは別に悪い決まりじゃないんです
それで 例えば子供はなんとか悪くても
後からもう ものすごくおとなしくなっちゃって
いい子で育てて それでいろいろ
例えば音楽をやりたくなったりしますね
友達と集まったら 5時からやっぱり 6時半まで練習するとかになっても
この子はやっぱり 6時に帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
で その場合は もう子はもう悪いことをするということはないんだと
もう今 普通にもうちゃんと成長しているんだと
もう問題はないんだと
あの精神不安定な状態はもう消えちゃったとわかったら
あの 6時に必ず帰れという規則を もうそれで解除しないと
だから目的が達成したら
計画はもう関係なくなるんですね
それが人間やらないんだから
目的はもう どうでもいいんです
決まりだから守りなさいと
だから仏教っていうのは
仏教でも決まりいっぱいありますけど
仏教は いつでも進歩的で
もう何でも適当に 考えながら変えていってほしいと
だから世界の 社会の進歩っていうのは
やっぱり壊してはいけないんですね
計画などを作ってしまうと
それを固定化して それに支配されるようになっちゃうと
社会が 1か所に留まるということになっちゃうんですね
そうすると 必ず破れて壊れてしまうんです
この世の中を見て お釈迦様
いろんなこのもう何百
何百万年前のとかね
わからないほど古い 社会にシステムについても 語っているところがありますけどね
いろいろこの社会システムが壊れていくというところは
この保守主義なんですね 一つ
で いろんな何か決めて
その決まりの中にぎっしりと人々を束縛しようとすると
もうどうにもならなくなって
それを壊してしまうという
で 次のポイントに行きますけど
この 立てた計画はうまくいってほしいんですね
これも誰でも 普通の願いなんですけどね
うまくいかないと占いに頼ったりします
方角も考えたりする
そういう迷信的なところまで 行ってしまうんですね
で なんでしょうかね 方位学やらね
占いやら かなりもう徹底的に信じている人々います
ちゃんとあの なんとかの人からもう なんとか風水占いをしてもらって
それからは大変収入も良くなって
もう家族の喧嘩もなくなって
子供も落ち着いてきたんだと
だから私はもう徹底的に信じているんだとかね
いう人々はいるんですけど
いくら言われても 私はそんなものは科学的な
きちんとした 客観的に見た 正しい判決だとは思わないんですね
ちょっと常識あればね
風水占いしなくてもね
枕はどこに置いて寝た方がいいかくらいは常識でもわかると思いますけど
玄関はどちらにあれを 周り見たらわかりますけどね
だからそれはしないんだからね
誰か風水とかなんとかの人に行ってもらって
やりますけどね そういう人々もいい加減でね
何言うかわかりませんね
どうしても もうドアがつけられないところに
こちらにドアがなければいけませんとか言っちゃうと
自分の国では 面白い話がありましてね
人が死んだら 遺体をお墓まで お墓ではなくて
墓地まで持っていかなくちゃいけないんだからね
それで占い師が占ってあげるんです
西から その日によってね
東を見て家から出ましょうと
あるいは西を見て 家の玄関はどちらに見ているかということを
また例えば 家の玄関はもう東の方だったら
占い師が もう西を見て持っていくと
壁を破らなくちゃいけないんです
そちら壁だから　一回話聞いて... 見たことはないんですけど
その占い師が言った方向はもうドアがないんです
それで棺をそこから外へ持っていかなくちゃいけないです
そうすると窓があって
窓を外して壁を破って
いくらか大きくして そこから苦労して棺を外へ出して
それからまた行列で持っていったと
だから なんでそこまで
無意味な 笑えることをするんでしょうかね
だから 占い師の話を聞かないと何かうまくいかないんだろうというね
危険だよということなんですね
だから我々 人生のいろんなことを計画している途中でうまくいかない時は
そうやって神秘に頼っちゃう
それに仏教の答えは因果法則なんです
だからできれば お釈迦様がおっしゃっている因果法則を勉強した方がいいんです
だから 困ったことをみんな伝統的に考えるんだから
因果法則と言った途端
十二因縁ではないかと
無明から行が生じるとかね
特にもう仏教の学者というのは 日本でたくさんいらっしゃいますからね
パーリ仏教の学者も日本にはたくさんいます
因果法則とは何でしょうかと聞いてみてください
必ず 無明から行が生じる というところから始まると思います
私の話なんか あの人は随分 好き勝手なことを言うんだよ
と言う可能性もあります
そういう意見はあまりにも対立するから 私は
学問的研究っていうのは一切やりませんと
いさぎよくやめたんです
今もそれを自慢に思っているんです
博士論文とかいろいろ書いてると
なんてアホでしょうかとかね
これぐらい苦労しても
これぐらいしか言えないで
それまた間違っているし
ですから この因果法則っていうのは何でしょうかね
それはどこにでもある 普遍的な科学的な法則なんです
結果は原因によるものだよと
それが因果法則なんです
無明から行が生じるという
そればっかりいちいち勉強したっても
生きる上ではそれ役に立つんでしょうかと
それがこの修行する人々に
悟りを開く前に 智慧が開発してもらわないと 悟れないんだから
この智慧の開発のために
真理の世界を理解するために教えているところであって
それは 一つのアプリケーションだけなんです
ですから この結果は 原因によるものだよと
それははっきりわかると 簡単に計画を立てられます
計画って何なのかって
仏教的に言えば ある望む結果を想定します
こういう結果を望んでますよと
それで その結果を出すために
現れるために どんな原因をそろえればよろしいかと
その原因がそろうことが
この原因 こういう原因だよと発見することが計画なんです
それを発見して じゃあそれからその原因をそろえてみましょうと
その原因が適当にそろったところで
適当な結果が必ず出ます
狂うことはないんです
だから計画性っていうのは
この原因結果のことで
いつでも望む結果というものを考えてほしい
世の中の計画はそういうものじゃないんです
全部もう計画のために 我々は生きているのであって
宗教の儀式儀礼とは何の変わりもないんです
飛行機の中でも お祈りしようと思っちゃうんだから
これは儀式儀礼であって
イスラム教のお祈りっていうのは
ちゃんと絨毯を敷いて メッカの方を見て
お祈りすることだから ちゃんと方位を教えてくれる
何て言いますか あれはコンパスとか持ってます みんな
でコンパスを開けたら ちゃんとメッカはこちらにいますよ
ちゃんと数字出るんですね
イスラム教の人々が使う時計でも
そういう機能がついているんです
ちゃんとメッカがあるところは ちゃんと示してるんです
だからどこにいても メッカはあるところは知ってます
でもね メッカはサウジアラビアにありますけど
地球の裏側にいると そこはどこを見てお祈りするんでしょうかと思い
思いたいんだけどね
だから論理的じゃない そこまで考えないんだよ
それでも方位でこっちへ行ったら
もうどこか見てやってますからね
だって丸いんだからね
メッカがあるところはこう 裏回っちゃうと
こうやって 逆立ちしてお祈りをしないと
だから そういうふうにも儀式儀礼になってくると
もうバカバカらしくなっちゃって
もう大変なんですね だから
仏教の因果法則を考えて 計画を立てるということは
望む結果がありますよと
そのために これこれの条件を揃えましょう ということであるならば
決してこの 何のためにということが忘れられません
だから我々は 因果法則を無視して計画を立てようとする
だから予定が狂っちゃうと
みんなこの大変困ったりします
がっかりするどころじゃなくて
もう本当に 自殺する人は結構いるんだから
人生の予定やら 全部狂っちゃったんだと
もう嫌だと言って自殺までする
そこまで不幸になるんですよ
それはみんな 因果法則なんかもう ひとかけらも見ようともしない
だから因果法則自体 何を教えてくれるかというと
これは物事っていうのは 私の希望通りに行くわけでもないし
あなたの希望通りに行くわけではありませんと
ということは 自と他だから
もっと俗っぽく言えば 神様の希望通りにも行きません 物事は
神様を信仰している方々は 気づいていないだけで
神様は希望して人類を創ったんだけど
神様の計画通りに動いていないんですね
信じている人よりは 信じない人の方が多いんです
だからはっきりしていますよ
絶対的な もう何て言いますか
全知全能の神だと 言ってはいるんだけど
神の希望通りに物事は行かないんです
どこでも だから客観的に見ればいいでしょうに
我こそ正しい神を信仰しているんだから
我こそ勝ちます 言っても負けっぱなしでしょうに
戦争して 戦争して
戦争はもうずっとありますからね
大体 仏教の影響はいくらかある国の人 ほとんど少ないんだから
日本にしても 他の国もね そんなにあったといっても早く
例えばカンボジアで激しく汚く
もう恐ろしい人殺しあったでしょうに
やめましょうと思ったら すごい簡単にやめちゃったでしょう
もうものすごい人を殺した人々も
恨みもなく もう今何のことなく 平和で生活しています
まあ完璧な平和っていうのは成り立ちませんだけど
やっぱり日本のテレビで見たんだけど
なんかこのもうたくさん人を村人でね
いろんな人のことを言っていて
殺されて殺して
その人は報告するんですね
その人の報告によって
その村の人々もかなり死んでしまったみたい
殺されたみたいです で
今 政権変わったところで
この人がこの村の大勢の 何百人も人々のことを報告して 密告して
殺したってことをみんな知ってるんです
でもその人はもう何もしません 誰も
その代わりに その人が自分がものすごい悪いことをしたんだと
ですから それはもうちゃんと あの 何て言いますか
罪滅ぼししなくちゃいけないんだと思って もう全くもう村も全部離れて
山の中にどうかな ちょっと洞窟みたいなものを作って
その中でなんか行者みたいな生活をしているんですね
死んだ人々に 仏教だからね
いろいろなことをして
回向したり 冥福を祈ったり
自分が一人で一生懸命
もう厳密にもう 聞いたらもう堂々と言う
私はそういうふうなことをしましたと
ですから ものすごい罪を犯しましたと
だから自分がこれからは修行に入って
なんとかその罪をなくすように
なんとかしなくて そうすると他の人々もそれをよく理解して
私はもう なんときれいな人々だなと
いわゆる村人のこと 殺された被害者の側から見ればね
その被害者っていうのはいかに立派かと
絶対的な誰かを信仰しているんだから
全ての物事うまくいくんだよと思っても
実際の世界を見るとそうはないんです
ですから 因果法則っていうのは
私の意見がその通りに行くということはありえないし
他の意見もその通りに行くということはありえないんです
これは自分と他人という 個人個人の問題ではありませんと
こんなものは法則ですよと
私が雨が降って欲しくないと思っただけで
雨が降ってこないと思うのは
バカもいいところでしょうに
私が雪が嫌だなと思っても
今ちょっと暑いんだから
雪ぐらいちょっと ふらっと降った方がいいんではないかなと思ってもね
そうはなるわけじゃないでしょうに
じゃあ それが神様が決めて降らしちゃうんですかね
神様にそんな力あるんだったら
じゃあ一回だけでもいいんだから
真夏に雪降らしてくれと
地球上みんなお願いしたらどうですかね
そうすると聞いてくれるかもしれません
かなり耳が遠いんですけど
誰も怖くてそんなチャレンジまでしないんだから
私だったらやりますけど
神を信じる人も信じない人
みんな一斉に 1日決めて
地球スケールで 今は一番 簡単にできますからね
情報ネットワーク 世界中いっぱいにできていますから
じゃあお祈りしてみましょうと
真夏に その真夏が空いてるこの国に 一回だけでもいいんだから
雪降らしてくれと できるかと
だから そんなもん
そんなこと言ったら それは神を侮辱することだとか
くだらんことを言う 侮辱じゃないでしょうに
全知全能だから それぐらいのこと
何にもないでしょうに
だから乱れてる人間をね
ちゃんと道に導くために
それぐらいのことをね
苦労しても 慈しみの神だから 何が悪いんですかね
だからそういうのは人間非科学的にいい加減で
感情で言うだけであって
物事っていうのは私の意見でも他人の意見でも行くわけじゃないんです
だから希望通りにいかないんだぞと いう仏教の教えは
それは頑固たる事実なんです
希望っていうのは私の主観だから
それでお釈迦様に文句言いたがるんですね
仏教は暗いやと
希望通りに行くようになんとかもう呪文でも唱えてくれるのはありがたいではないかとかね
何か 護摩供養でもしてくれたらどうでしょうかねとかね
頼んだらやりますよ 私に頼んだらお金くれるんだったらやりますけど
自分では信じてないんですけど
それはお金必要です 説法は無料でしますけどね
インチキだったらお金必要なんです
ですから
どうでもいい うまくいかなかったらね
もうあなたの運が悪いとかね
あなたちゃんと 心は正直で 心を集中してね
きちんと参加しなかったんだから
私知りませんよ それはそれだけのことでしょうと
みんなそうやってこの こういうね
祈祷系の人々がみんなそうやって責任逃れでしょ
私たちみたいに すごい凶暴で チャレンジしてしゃべれないでしょう
私だったら じゃあやってみなさいよ
もし間違いあったら言ってみなさいよ
はっきりと チャレンジしてしゃべってるでしょう
これがこれ 1日 2日 3日でもやってみなさい
もし結果がなければ ちゃんと言ってる
あるいは言っていることに 何か間違いでもあるんだったら
堂々と言ってみてください
私はちょっと凶暴すぎて
みんなもうチャレンジ 攻撃したい気持ちあったって
なんか怖くてやらないということもあります
それは私の失敗で
もうちょっと 穏やかにしゃべった方がいいな という気持ちはあるんだけど
どうも癖だからね これはもうどうにもならんことで
でもできればね 私はものすごい強烈な返事するかもしれませんだけど
それにめげずに チャレンジしても決して構いません
我々それは慣れてます
このお互いに対立して話し合うとかね
決して否定されたんだからといって 落ち込むということは全くないんです
反対論 異論いっぱい出されて
どうしようもない 嫌だとかね
怒りになったとか それはないんです
あ それがみんな元気でよかったと
今日はかなり もうやりがいがあったと
という気分だけです ですからね
一応慣れてはいます 反論には
だから ちょっと出してみてもよろしい
とにかく 責任逃れはしないんです
きちんと事実を語っているつもりですから
やってみてくださいと
もし異論があったら言ってみてくださいと
という状態で喋ってます
それは私の強さではなくて
お釈迦様の強さなんですけど
それでこの 因果法則に戻りますけど
因果法則をちゃんと理解する人が
私の主観は その通りに通るということはありえないんだと
それは自分の場合で気づきますかと
全然気づくことないんだ
だって他の人の場合も同じことだから
誰の主観もそんな簡単にいくわけじゃないんです
例えばね 今の総理大臣たる小泉さんにしても
やりますと言うんだけど
かなり緊張していますよ
いろいろ反論があるんだっていう
それはちゃんと承知の上で
やらせてはくれませんということがね
ちゃんと知っています
だからその方が もうなんとかやりますという気持ちではいるんですけど
だからといって もうあれほどね
もう国民が賛成しているんだから
政治家の人々がね もう協力すればいいでしょうに
協力しないんだから ですから
それぐらい力ある人にしたって
自分の主観が一方的にいくということはないんですよ
それは普遍的な事実なんです
そんなところが小泉さんのところか
もう絶対 神様の意見さえも うまくいかないんだから
だから聖書を読んでも
他の宗教の聖典を読んでみても
口先だけは言います すべて私の希望通りにいくんだぞと
すべて私が決めるんだぞとかね
あんなものは脅しであって
子供だましだと思います
だって 実際に世の中を見ると
誰の意見も そんなうまくいってるはずがない
いってるわけじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が因果法則として
これは 世の中にはいろいろ原因があって
その原因によって結果が出てくるんだよと
それは誰の意見というわけでもないんです
そこで人の意見というのは
主観というのはすごく弱いんだけど
一つの原因にはなります
だから無数の原因の中でたった一つなんです
だからまるっきり自分の意見は通らないかというと
そうでもないんです でも我々は
例えば 1万の原因の中でたった一つぐらい
一つ自分の意見 それだけ通ってほしい
それだけ通ってほしいというのは あまりにも論理的じゃないんです
だから計画を立てるということは
その因果法則によってやることで
この結果は 望ましい結果だよと
その結果になるために
こういうふうに 条件をそろえればいいんではないかなと
それぐらいのことで考えていると がっかりすることはないんです
だから この計画の中で自分の主観
どれぐらい機能しているかと
そこをちょっと考えた方がいいんですね
例えば 20人集めて何かしようとする
どうしても人間が集めたら
一人がリーダーみたいなものは出てくる
そうでないと まとまらないんだから
それでリーダーが出てきても
リーダーの意見というのは 20分の1なんです
で リーダーが 私はこういうふうなことを考えましたけどと言って
そればっかり通してもらおうと思っちゃうと
単なる独占 独裁ですね
そうすると 他の人々はとにかく壊してしまう可能性もあります
それで人が がっかりする
だから自分の意見はどんなパーセントかということは 考えた方がいいんです
会社の社長が 今年はこれぐらい儲かりますよと計画を立てても
自分の欲望だけでうまくいくわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそれは会社の社長の希望であって
それは一つの原因であって
またたくさん原因があるんですね
なんで自分の原因だけに
この 50%以上重みを入れるなくちゃいけないんですかね
それは 50%じゃなくて
1万分の1ぐらいのことなんです
例えば その会社で 100人仕事をしているんだったら 100分の1ですよ
社長の意見というのは
だって他の人と仕事をしなきゃ うまくいかないんだから
それでじゃあ 100人も同じ意見になったとして成功しますか？しないでしょうに
会社って何か仕事をするところだから
それまた社会ということの反応によって成り立ちますから
自分が儲かるぞと 儲かりたいんだからといって店を作って開いても
90%でお客さんの手に成功はね
お客さんが来るか来ないかということによって成り立つんです
店を開いた人の気持ちじゃないんですね
だからその辺で我々のは
この科学的な 論理的に因果法則を理解しないんだから
みんながっかりするんです
予定が狂ったら 人生まで狂ってしまうんです
だから因果法則を知ってるんだったら
予定が狂うということさえも 成り立たないんです
本当はそれ非論理的なんです
なんで予定が狂うんですかね
おかしいでしょう 私は予定が狂うという言葉さえ成り立たない
予定が狂ったということは
非科学的で 因果法則を無視して
私が作った計画がこの通りに行くはずでしたよと
その時点でもう完璧な非科学的な
もう原始人だから
だから本当は もうちょっと知識人になるならば
予定が狂ったんだということさえも成り立たないんです
例えば何か予定があって
それはうまくいかなかった場合
狂ったとは言わないんです
こういう予定でしたけど
他の条件が出てきて変わりましたと
今日はハワイに遊びに行く予定でしたけど
あの 突然もう会社に呼ばれて
緊急事態で 休暇を取り消されちゃったんだよと
予定が狂ってどうってことはないんで その場合は
ただ 原因 条件変わっただけのことだから狂わないんですよ
だから最初に言ったように
予定が狂ったと思うこと自体もおかしいんです
だから常に私の意見は通りません
他の意見も通るわけじゃない
物事は法則によって動くものだと
それで自分には望む結果があるんだったら
ちょっと この原因をちょっと
何て言いますか 調整してみる
例えば糖尿病の人が どうしてもケーキを食べたくなっちゃうと
望む結果は ケーキ食べたいという
でも自分にとっては 食べてはいけないんだと
いけないことでも できないわけないでしょ
因果法則を知ってるんだったら できます
糖尿病であろうとも ケーキは食べたいんだよという望みが出てきたら
じゃあケーキは食べたいんですけど
これ毎日パクパク食べるわけにはいきませんと
まあ一回ぐらいは この どうしても食べたいんだからね
これはちょっと気持ちが落ち着かないんだと
じゃあ一回 食べるんだったらどうすればいいかと
じゃあ 朝ご飯をパスして
ケーキにしますとかね
昼 私は一応なんか これ食べてますけど
じゃあこれはやめて ケーキ 1個食べてコーヒー飲もうかなとかね
そういう風に 自分のことじゃない 体にしても
だから入る糖分と 自分の出すインスリン ならその計算がありますから
そこら辺でちょっと調整変えれば ケーキは食べられますでしょうに
全く食べられないというわけじゃないんです
あるいは糖尿病なんて
私は神様を信仰しているんだから
いっぱいケーキ食べて
余分にお祈りしますよと
病気にならんようにとかね
そんなことはありえないんだからね
毎日 5分お祈りするんだけど
今日は 15分にしますと
それでケーキいっぱい食べますと
病気にならないんだとかは ありえないんでしょう
だから普段 無理と思うものでも
因果法則を知っているならば
いくらかは可能にすることはできます
そのように考えると
我々にはやっぱり どうしても変えられないこともあると
例えば ヒマラヤなんかを登ってみたいなとかね
地球の頂上だから 悪くないんですけどね
登る人はアホですけど
登っても 別に悪くはないんですけど
だって何もないんだから 登ったって
で それで原因を変えればいいんですね
それで原因を変えようと構ったところで
登山の訓練しなくちゃいけないし
季節の変化やらね そういういろいろ訓練しなくちゃいけないんですね
ヒマラヤの場合は　普通の山とは違いますからね
で かなり訓練が必要なんです
それはやってみようかなと思ったら
自分の年やらね いろんなものと計算しちゃうと
これは無理とわかるでしょうね
やめる やめればいいんです
で あ 自分にとってはその条件だったらなんとかなりますよと思ったら
もうなんとかすれば登れないわけでもないんです
ですから このあれが無理
これが無理というふうに諦めことも
その主義もあまりよくない
やればできるんだよと
でもやれば確実にできるのではなくて
それは因果法則によるものだと
だから因縁を揃えることができれば
何のことなくできますよと
だから いつでも自分の主観というのは
派手に出さないこと いわゆる望む結果っていうのは 自分の主観だから
それぐらいにしておいて
こういうふうになればいいなと　それだけに
それから 自分でやるものではないんだと
他は世の中の原因なんです
それはきちんと論理的に整理してみる
それが仏教的な計画なんです
何か紙の上でいろいろ図を描いたり いろいろやったとしても
そうするとちょっと おかしくはなります
いくら描いて 計画を立てても
やっぱり因果法則だから 常に調整しなくちゃいけないという
だから予定は狂わないんです
例えば 50人が集まるということであって
そこで50人に食事しなくちゃいけないんだ
それで注文しましたと
注文したところで電話かけてみたら
なんでまだ弁当来ないんですか？って
その店の人 何？そんな契約受けてないんですけどと
言われるとどんな調子？こちら50人集めて
9時 10時から集めて話し合って
12時になったところで みんなで弁当を食べて
それから12時半からまた 次の会議をやりましょうという決まりだとしましょう
それで11時になっても弁当来る気配はない
11時半になってもないと
これ心配する それで店に電話してみたところで
店は全然知らないと 言っちゃうとどうなりますかね
みんな狂っちゃうと思いますけど
そういう切羽詰まってる状態というかね
私の人生ではもう結構ありましたけど
いきなり あ どうしようかと
私はその瞬時に じゃあ こういうことだから
今はこういうふうに原因を変えればいいんじゃないかなと
すぐ原因を変えるんです
あるいは注文頼んだ人に言って
その人に怒鳴ったりとかね
なんで あなたちゃんとやってないんですか？とかね
そんなことではないんです
だから今11時半 弁当は来ないと
で それで私だったら 私はちょっと そっち用事があるんだから
30分抜けますと どうぞやってくださいと言って
なんとか他のことをするんです
走って そこら辺にある
車でも借りて そこら辺にあるいろんな弁当屋さんからね
もうコンビニから集めるか
あるいは何のことなく報告して
実はこういうふうに12時に弁当を食べる予定でしたけど
突然それ取り消しになりましたと
ですから申し訳ないんですけど
12時になったら皆様方は そこら辺の店に行ってご飯を召し上がってくださいと
もしこちらからあげるだったら
こちらから全部 領収書を持ってきたらお金払いますよと
そういうふうに決めましたよ
向こうは こちら狂ってるとわかったらまずいと思ったら
一応その方が 皆様は好きなものを食べられますから
こちら金額はこれぐらい
一人1500円に決めてましたから
その範囲でどうぞご自由に 気持ちいくままに召し上がって
1時に集まってください　ありがとうございます
ったらもうバレないでしょう
だからそれは別に 計画が狂ったっていうことはなく
原因ちょっと変えてみるだけのことなんです
一回 自分の国で お寺でやるお坊さん
自分のお寺ではないんだけどね
外国からかなりの人気のお坊さんが来るということで
そのお寺の関係あるお坊さんですけど
そこでお寺に呼んで もう大いに歓迎会やりますと
で 私はその人にあなたね
ちょっとやめた方がいいんだ
あんまりにも大きなスケールで
これ無理だと 突然
大丈夫 みんなに言ってるんだから
あなたも来てくださいと
それはちょっと私は心配だ と言っても
その人はあまりにも有名な人で
他のところ いろんなところで歓迎会やってるんだからね
そちらに行って我々も参加すれば それで済むもんだよと
いえいえ もともとこのお寺のお坊さんだから こちらでやらなくちゃ
ああそう じゃあ言うんだったら その日に来ますよ
言ったら このお坊さんがすごい威張って
いろんなところにお坊さんたち呼んでるんです
知ってる人やら友達やら
あっちからこっちから
それでたくさんのお坊さんたちが集まっちゃったんです
でもあのグループの中の5人なんです
その5人にはなんとか食事はありましたけど
他のお坊さんたちはどうしますか？
そのお坊さんが 住職さんが全然 もうもう何ですかね
私は言ってるんだけど まだ来てないんですよ とか言ったら
他の弟子がいてね この人は全然やってないんだと
私は全然気にしない 私に関係ないんですけど
私はやっぱり 外から来たお坊さんたちにとっては
これ大変な迷惑でしょうに
何のことなく自分に車もありますし
もう一人 あなたの車を貸せと
もう一人の人は車貸して
お坊さんみんな車に乗って言ったら
もうみんな 私はすごい気楽に言うんだからね
みんな みんな
あなた 乗って乗ってって
そのまま街に連れて行ったんです
と言って ある一つの店に行ってみたんです
そしたらこれ イスラム教の店で レストラン
11時半にお祈りするんだから
店を閉めてあったんです
だからお客さんがいないんです
で 向こうはスリランカでお坊さんたちとイスラム教とは
ずいぶん仲がもう全く ものすごい仲がいいんで
こういうふうにいろいろ批判するんだけど
決して仲が悪いわけじゃないんです
だから何のことなくドアを開けて中に入ったら
みんな あ お坊さんなんですか　なんですかではなくて
大変なことになります
私はもう三十人のお坊さんたちがいるんだけどね
もう早くご飯作って食べさせなくちゃいかんだけど
あなた方できますか？と
困ってますよ と言ったら
実は 我々のお祈りの時間なんで
だから店は閉めてますけど
一応 商売するんだから 食事全部作って用意してはいますけど
それからずっともう 夜までやってますからね
用意はしてますけど
12時15分 12時半で店開けますよと
そんなこと言っても私は困りますけどと
言ったら何のことはない
わかりました どうぞどうぞ
みんな来てください 誰もない店でみんなお坊さんに座ってもらって
それで私もまた向こうのことを心配して
でもあなた方お祈りはどうしますかと
言ったら大丈夫 それはもう簡単にやりましたと
やってないと思いますけどね
だから それもお互い仲がいいんだからね
こちらが心配してるんだから
向こうはちゃんと それはちょっと調整してくれたことで
だからなかなか喧嘩できませんね
お互いに助け合ってますから
で なんのことなく無事に問題終わって
お坊さんたちにも 知ってる人にお坊さんたちにはね
あの坊主野郎ね ぶん殴ってやりたいと言ってんだけど
他のあまり知らないお坊さん
そんなこと言わなかったし
あの で 問題は何のことなくもう解決しました
でないと大変なことになります
1日 もうご飯もなくなっちゃうんだから
遠くから来て 呼ばれて
お寺関係っていうのは結構きついものでしょうし
だからそうやって 突然もうなんとかなるということは 当然ある
その瞬間でちょっと考えて
原因 またちょっと調整してやる
だから 私もいろいろ計画立てたりしますけど
大体 私の一つのずるいことがありますけど
あまり計画は明確に言わない
こういう計画で こういう目的
こういうふうにするんだぞと
なぜかというと そうするとみんな迷っちゃうんです
いくつかあります　まず理解しない
まずできっこはないと
それから あれやこれやと批判ばっかしで
でないと 私は原因だけそろえて考えてもらって
あなたはこれやってくれますかと
あなたはこれやってくれますか？と言って
そろえて 必要になっているところを
かすかに計画の目的の図を かすかに見えるように
薄暗く見えるようにする
それでみんな なるほどうまくいったもんだなと
でも私はうまくいくという 100パーセント自信があるわけじゃなくて
原因が変わったらすぐこうします
これ変わったらこうしますと
いくらでもこの選択っていうのは無制限にある
ない場合はないストップ　堂々とストップする
例えば 何か買おうと思ったところで お金がないと
やめればいいでしょうに そんなに
もう 2 3回やったんです
何か計画を立てて もう日にちもないんだから
何か店に行って ああ この日で行きますよと
いって もう慌ててもう店に行って
じゃあこれ どうぞちょうだいと言って
はいと言って じゃあお金出すの　お金がない
何か言い訳して いいわ
今度 買いますから
何のこともなく帰ります
だから条件変えることができれば変えちゃう
変えなかったら 別に計画はそのままです
ストップになるしか方法ないんだから
それは失敗でも何でもないんだよ
因果法則だから 自分の意見で物事行くわけじゃないし
他人の意見で物事行くわけでもないし
時々この品物はすごくいいものだと言っても
一生懸命店の側が説明しちゃうと
それは買いたくないんだったら
いろいろ条件変えて 本人に言わせるんです
そんなろくなものではないと
だからもうそれ知ってるとうまくできるんだ
だからこっち逃げる方法もないしね
こういうことで 私はちょっと見て
この人のいい説明
言ってる説明も聞いて
この場合はどうしますかね これは
こうなったらどうします？言ったら向こうがどうしようかなとかね
また困っちゃうんですね
予測してなかったものだから
そうですね やっぱりね
私はそれ そうすると終わり 話が
だから ある面で言えば
自分の希望通りに行くといえば 希望通りに行くことで
別に自分の希望というものでもなくて
客観的な因果法則
考えれば 計画狂うということは成り立たないんです
だからこのずっと 神様に恵まれてとかね
特別な守護神に 自分が特別に守られてとかね
そんなことを考えちゃうと 人間ダメになるんです
智慧には勝てないんだと 誰でも
智慧こそもう武器だと
瞬間瞬間の判断能力こそ人間にとっては武器だと
それには神も恐れますよと思って
きちんと客観的に物事を見て調整しておけば
計画狂うということはなりたたない
なぜ私は調整という言葉を使いますかと
それも考えてですね 調整っていうのは初めから終わるまでやるもんなんですよ
調整しまして はい 終わりということはないんです 調整だから
だから計画っていうのは 固定したものじゃないんです
一旦こうことだと決めてから この実行する上で
最初のところに来るまで調整っていうのは ずっと必要なんです
車の運転だと思ってみれば
一旦 エンジンかけた時から エンジンかけてギアを入れた時から
止まるとこまで ずっと調整しなくちゃいけないでしょう
エンジンかけてギアを入れて アクセラレイトを踏む
それで車は動く それで動きますかね
動くのは動くんだけど
そこら辺に壁にぶつかっちゃって死んじゃいますからね
ですから そこから自分の目的ところに行って
車は駐車して エンジンを切るところまで
調整 調整
それを因果 それが因果法則で
それ忘れてはいけません
そうすると狂ったっていうことはないんです
何でも調整 例えば どこかに行こうと思って
自分が真剣 真面目に車を運転して行く
自分の原因ではないんだけど
他人の原因で車がぶつかったりします
そうすると目的地に行けないんですね
どうやって調整すればいいんですかね
どこかへ出かけようと用事があって
結婚式でもよろしいし
葬式でもいいんです 葬式がありますと
で 高速道路に行ったところで
なんかどこかから車が滑ってきて
自分の車にバーンとぶつかっちゃったら
調整する人は事故を起こしませんからね
ですから 厳密に調整する人がいる
因果法則を知っている人がいる
その人はすごい丁寧にちゃんと車を運転して行く
その時でも 何か突然来て ぶつかったりします
それもこの調整が下手なんです
時々の高速道路の事故なんか見てみると
やっぱりみんなダメだなと
大体 避けられるものって ものすごく多いんです
時々トラックなんかね
荷物を載せて いきなりブレーキかけたりしたら
後ろもの長いから 横になったりしますね
そうすると横になっただけでいって
なんで次から次へと 車が行ってぶつかるんですかね
みんな どこを見て運転しているんですかと聞きたいんですけど
常に調整っていうことを忘れちゃうんです
高速道路だから
ただアクセル踏んだままで じーっとバカみたいに見ているんだから
それでもそうやって 次から次へとぶつかって
だからいつでも前の車に合わせてこちらずっといないと
大体見えますよ 車の後ろ見ると相手の心まで 私には見えますけど
分かりませんけどね
大体 不安定な人か 祈りしているかとかね
凶暴な人かとか 性格まで見えますよ
車の後ろの方を見ても
だからこの人はちょっと 乱暴で凶暴だと思ったら
こちらはそれなりに 自分で合わせると
そうすると スピードもありますから
このブレーキかけて車止まるわけですから
もしかすると ぶつかるぐらいのことはあるかもしれませんだけど
そんなにも危険にはならないと思います
とにかく調整っていうのは かなり下手な
だから事故を起こしちゃいますよ
特に日本で事故を起こすこと自体
私はおかしいと思います
これぐらい厳密にすべて整理し 整備してあって
それでまた みんなものすごい決まり守ってやってるのに
事故あること自体おかしいんです
それはもう頭が悪いとしか言う方法もないのです
それぐらい全部きちんと計画立ててきちんとできているのに
だから自分の国と比べて言うんです
何一つもないんだから
そんなものは 道路は狭いし
狭い代わりに道路を見えない車ばっかしで
そういうところで 何も誰も決まり守ってないんだからね
高速というのは一つも誰も守ってない
だからそこら辺で事故を起こしちゃっても当たり前ということになりますけどね
日本では事故あったらおかしい
とにかくそんな話でもいいんですけど
例えばそうやって葬式に行こうといったところで
高速道路で突然ぶつかってしまったとします
そこで常に物事を調整する人はどうすればいいんですか？と
事故を起こしちゃったら もういけないでしょう
だから次の調整っていうのは事故の処理なんでしょうに
葬式どうしようと どうでもいい
もういけない
ストップ　終わり　だから気楽でいられます
葬式にももう行けないんだからね
で 警察やらいろいろ呼んでみましょうと
そこら辺でこういうことで病院に行ったら
じゃあ病院に運びましょうとかね
向こうの車も病院に行ったら
もうその何とか助けて
はい はい　どうぞ どうぞとかね
じゃあ あなたじっとこちらにいてくださいとか
救急車を呼びますからとかね
そういうそこら辺で調整すれば抜群でしょうね 人生は
例えば これ友人やらその葬式です
ただ 自分がどうしても参加しなくちゃいけない
自分の家のね 誰かの葬式であろうと
私だったら 電話ぐらいかけて
こういうことになったんだから
そちらちゃんとやってくださいと
お客さんに失礼だからと一言は言って
別に気にしない 来た方々に失礼だからちゃんとやってくださいと
それで家の人々は それでも何もできないんだったら
葬儀屋さんがいるんで
その人に電話かけて言うんです
あなたきちんとやりなさい
もう私は来られませんと
事故を起こしちゃったんだから
だから家の人々は何もわからなくて
もうがっかりしているかもしれません
だからそこら辺ちゃんと面倒見てよと頼みますよと
それで終わります
だから解決できないということはありえないんです
だから 狂ったというのは
とにかく自分が行かなくちゃいかないとか
そうやってこの自分の自我で物事を考える時なんで
そうでなきゃ別に調整予定来るってありえない
成り立たないんです
その場 その場でも原因 変わりますから
自分の意見で行くわけじゃないんです
冬だったら 知らないところ
もしどこかちょっと氷でもあったら
見えなかったらどうしますか？滑っちゃうでしょう
その瞬間で じゃあそれだったらこうしますという
だからこの瞬間で判断できるということが
この原因論をきちんと身につけている人なんです
ああ 原因が変わったら結果も変わったんだそうと
だから次にどういうふうに原因を調整しますかと
その瞬間で見れればいいんですね
それは仏教の立場から見る計画的な生き方なんです
それであの話は終了したいんですけど
また大体 世の中で嫌がるもう一つ話があります
無常の話
それお釈迦様は 単純なことを教えてるんだよとか
失礼なことを思うかもしれませんけど
これが ものすごく大事な真理なんです
物事は無常であると
物事 無常だったら 計画は立てられるわけではない と思うでしょう
無常だから計画立てられます
無常でなきゃ 自分が勝手に計画立てたってどうにもならないんです
定めた方向へ行くんだから
物事にも もう定めたとかなんともないんです
無常ですから もう次から次へと変化する
ですから 変化する流れを 我々がいろいろ条件変えて
流れを少々変えることはできます
それが正しい計画なんです
年は取りたくないんだぞ と計画を立てて
いろんなことを食べたり
運動したりしても
それは無常に逆らうことであって
成り立たないことです
どうしても年取る
それはもう避けられない 無常だからと
だから 年取る過程をちょっと調整しましょうと
年を取っても 寝たきりにならないようにとかね
で 何て言いますか 脳出...何とかね
そういう風にならないようにとかね
心臓の血管が硬くならないようにとかね
それぐらいの調整は不可能ではありません
それで年取ることをやめて
私は 80歳になっても
いや  30代の元気でいたいとかね
言っちゃうと それはあまりにも主観であって 成り立たない
物事はどうしても止まることなく変わっていくんです
変わっていく流れをちょっと変えてみるということはできます
だから 川と同じ 川の流れを止めるということはできません
川の流れを止めちゃうと
これは大変なことになるんです
大変な危険な結果になります
ですから 私たちには 川の流れを好きなように調整はできます
役に立つように 役に立つように川の流れを変えたんだからって
川の流れがなくなるわけじゃないんです
どうせ流れている川だから
こういうふうにちょっと調整した方がちょっと役に立ちますよと
そういうふうなことが正しい計画なんです
ですから 無常ということは大変 大事な教えで
これは大事な教えというのは失礼なんです
それが事実であって それを忘れちゃうとすべて狂ってしまっている
それで忘れない人にとっては何も狂うことはないんです
すべて常に無常で変わるんだと
で 変わるんだということを知っている人には
変わり方をちょっと
どうせ変わるんだったら
こういう風にすればどうでしょうかと
例えば子供はどうしても家出したがっている
これはもう変化だからやめられませんね
家にいなさいと言っても
子供って大きくなりますからね
どうしてももう家出
するんだから だったらあなたはこうすればどうでしょうかと
ちょっと変えてあげればいいんじゃないんです
そうすると自分も子供も安心でしょうに
とにかくもう計画もなしにもうとにかく東京に行くんだとか
なんとかあると それで親がやっぱりあなたも大人だから
もうそろそろ家出した方がいいんだよと言って
とりあえずあなた 1年間ぐらいどこか外国で留学でもしたらどうですかね
家出する前に
それでどこかに外国の学校に何か話をつけちゃって
自分で行ったらいいけど
それで家出よりはショック多いんだからね 子供にとっては
それで悪くなるわけでもないし
ものすごい心配もあるし
きちんといて それで留学もして
勉強もして 一人前になって
もう帰って一人で生活するようになるんです
それに逆らおうとするんだから
親と喧嘩してとにかく飛び出ていく
本人もどうするか分からなくて
人生どうなるか分からなくなっちゃう
それで両側も心配で不幸になるんです
ですから この変化に逆らうんじゃなくて
変化をちょっと調整してみるということ
それが無常をうまく使う方法なんです
で そうすると決して
またかえって狂ったというね ことはないんです
だからどういう風になってもいいんです
次にどうする?　だからもう私の一つの生き方なんですけど
もう何かあったら大変だと思わないんです
何かあった瞬間に私は考えるのは 次にどうしますか？と
もう起きたこと もう起きちゃったんだから
ああ 大変だ どうしようということがなくて
じゃあ次にどうしますかと
そうすると悩む暇がないんです
次の何かできること 何なのか
何なのか そこばっかり頭が行くんだから
だからこの 無常を知っていると
そういうふうに大変楽に生きていられます
なぜならば 我々生きるということは無常でしょうしね
もう生まれた時からずっと 変わって変わって生きている
それは生きているということもするし
ご飯を食べたら無常だからご飯消化するし
花が咲くのも花が散るのも両方無常でしょうし
だから無常でなければ何一つも成り立ちませんし
無常でなければこの光も電気も何もないし
無常でなければ私もしゃべることもできないし
皆様に聞くこともできないし
聞いた話を覚えておくこともできないし
だから世の中何一つ成り立ちません
地球も宇宙も何一つも
全てもう常に変化するということで成り立ってるんです
それに逆らうのはもう無知もいいところなんです
永遠ということを思うこと自体も
もう無知の無知なんです
それはもう暗闇なんです
暗黒なんです
永遠 永遠 なんとか考えちゃうと　ありえないんです
だから永遠の天国なんかは
仏教では全然 考えてもないんだ
もうあんまりの無知な人を考えることであって
無常に逆らおうと　無常に逆らうんじゃないんです
すべて無常なんです 瞬間しかないんです
で その中で一時的にちょっと流れを変えてみるとかね
無常でなきゃ子供には勉強できません
だから子供はどんな学校に入るかということによって
子供の将来は決められるでしょう
だからそれは無常だからありえることであって
必ずしもこの子は悪い子になるんだよとかね
すごい立派に勉強するんで
そんな決まり 定めがないんです
入れた学校 入れた環境はもう変なんだったら 変な結果になるし
それなりのしっかりした環境に入れちゃうと しっかりした人になるし
それは無常だからそうなるんです
子供の主観でうまくいくわけじゃないんです
たとえ勉強したくない
もう私はふざけて遊び回りたいと思う人であろうとも
それなりのところに入れちゃえば
じゃあやってみなさいと
できないんですよ　もう自分の意見通るわけじゃないんだから
それで立派になります
ですから もう不可能はないんですよ
例えば 我々 インド文化系の人々みたいに
子供が生まれたらすぐにもう 星を計算して運命を占ってみるんですね
そうすると この子はこうなるんだ
ああなるんだとか インチキなことをいろいろ言うんです
そんなことを信じ込んじゃうと どうにもならんのだから
たとえ占い師は この子はもう決して勉強には向いてないんだよと言っても
それなりの環境を作っておけば
何のことなく勉強します
だから環境から独立して生きるってことは ありえないんです
だから自分の意見というのは通らない
自分の希望なんかは決して叶わないんです
もともと 一度でも
未知の過去から 未知の未来まで
人の希望っていうのは叶ったことない
そんなもうインチキです
我々はもう誤解しているだけで
これ私の希望が叶ったわけじゃなくて
ただ そういうふうな結果になったんであって
その結果 自分でも望んでいた それだけのこと
あ その結果だったら悪くないなと 自分が思うだけのことなんです
希望が叶ったというのは
例えば 人に何かものすごい高額の
もう馬券でも当たったとする
その人は自分の希望が叶ったそうと思ったと
それは勘違いであって
その人の友達に聞いてみてください
あれは悪いことやで それでよかったねと思いますから
そうすると友達の希望も叶ったことになるでしょう
だから たまたま起きた出来事は自分から見れば悪くないと
その方がいいということに 希望が叶ったと勘違いする
希望叶うということは成り立たないことで
一つの原因にはなりますけど
それなりに条件揃えば うまくいく可能性はいくらでもありますということで
ですから 無常ということも
ものすごい真剣に 生きる哲学にしないと
明るく生きていられません
無常に逆らっちゃうと 大変なことになる
例えば計画狂ったんだからといって落ち込む人っていうのは
無常に逆らおうとしているだけ
そんなもん狂っちゃいますよと
狂っちゃえば こうすればいいんじゃないかと思えば
それだけで問題は解決する
そういうことだから たとえ家が火事になっても悲しくなる必要はないんです
家が火事になんで悲しくなるの？もう家に住めないんだから
次に夜寝るところ探せばいいでしょう
今日はどこに寝ればいいかと
次にどうするべきかということだけ考えれば
友人がいるならば 親戚がいるならばそちらに行く
で なければそこら辺のどこか ホテルでも行くとか
次のこと必ずもありますからね
それ無常と同時に 今日時間はないんですけど
この時間論というのを覚えた方がいいんですね
時間というのは 時間はないんだけど
時間というものはないんだけど
あるのは現象ですけど
現象というのは止まることなく変化するんだということは
仏教の時間論なんです
それはもう どうにもならんことで
もう一つは時間論でいうのは
例えば米をご飯になるまでは30分かかりますね
いくら我々は急いでいても
米を洗って 水を入れて 炊飯器に入れて スイッチを入れると
もう30分ぐらいかかったところで ちゃんと食べられる美味しいご飯が出来上がる
それはもう薪で ものすごい猛烈な
火を炊いて 釜で焼いていても ご飯にはなりません
ただ焼けてしまうだけ
炭になるかもしれません
ですから たとえ薪でご飯を炊いても
もう30分以上かかるということは決まってます
それでも減らすことも延ばすこともできない
それから保存時間を見ても
例えば米だったら1年ぐらいでも保存状態によって食べられます
悪くならない でもご飯になったら1日以内で食べないと
もう食べるものにならないんです
今は冷蔵庫とかいろいろあるんだから
ちょっと冷凍庫に入れちゃえば 持ちますけど
冷凍庫に入れても
これは 2 3年持つということはないんです
せいぜい1ヶ月間ぐらいですからね
ですから なんで米は1年持つのに
ご飯は1日だけですか やっぱりご飯にはご飯の時間がある
米には米の時間があるということは
米という現象が食べられる現象としている時間なんですね
それで 店から大根買って 豆腐買ってきます
大根は来週でも食べられます
買ってきた豆腐は今日食べないと
そういう風に各物に これはもうあまり正しい言葉じゃないんだけど
各現象が自分の時間を持っています
いわゆるその現象が変化する時間ですよ
違うものになる時間 それはもうどうにもならんこと
じゃあ電気のスピードを速くすることできますか？もっと早く電気を流しておこうかなとか
できませんね そういうふうにできません
ですから 人生慌てる必要ないんです
慌てるのは この時間のわからない
無常わからない人なんです
綺麗に自然に全部 流れているんです
こちらがいくら嫌がっても
もう55(才)を飛んじゃったんだからね
まあ なるべきものは綺麗になるんです
そんな慌てても焦っても
何の意味もないんです
ですから この計画やら何やらね
そんなことを考えても
現象が その現象の時間に応じて動いているんだと
それに自分の欲望を出しちゃって 苦労する必要はないんだと
その中で生きている人
その現象だから どう調整すればいいかなと
それだけ覚えておけばいいんです
買ってきた豆腐は1日で食べられなくなりますけど
それでも今日は食べられませんと
明日も出かけますから食べられないんだと思っちゃうと
でも捨てるのはもったいないんだと思ったら
どうしますか  火を通す
それもその方法ですけど
それでも悪くなっちゃう可能性もあるしね
なんとか方法で
保存するようにしておけばね
あるいは水をギューっと切って
溝の中にでも置いておけば
悪くならないんですけど
で もうそのまま食べられるし
どうでもいいんですけど
とにかく 焼いておくか揚げておくか
どちらでもいいんですけど
なんとかすればっていう
そういうふうなことでね
だから何かの調整はできます
何の調整もできないものは
諦めるんですよ
それはものすごい自然なんです
じゃあ 自分の台所にあるガラスを
もうカップが割れたとします
どうしますか？その時は
泣く もう割れちゃったんだから諦めるでしょうに
そのままゴミ箱に入れるでしょうに
だからもうどうにもならないことはすぐ諦める
それは常にやっていますから
なんでそれは人生哲学に持ってこないんですかね
なんであれだけはどうしても諦められませんとか言って悩むんで
それはバカバカしいでしょうに
カップが割れちゃったら平気に捨てるんだから 諦めちゃって
服が破れちゃったら もう平気で諦めるでしょう
時々美味しそうに弁当持って行って
もう公園で食べようと思っても
口まで運ぶ これが美味しい
だして ふとんと落ちちゃうんです
落ちちゃうとまた拾って
それはないでしょうに
もう諦めるそれを
それ食べられないんだけど
やっぱりあのエビ食べたかったんだ
もう私にとってはすごく好物でしたのとか
それは無知バカでしょうに
だから物事っていうのは
もう終わったものはすぐ諦める
豆腐はやっぱり 捨てるのもったいないなと思ったら
だったらなんとか調整する
調整はありえないんだったら
もうポイと捨てるだけのことでしょうに
ですから 無常っていうのは大変なこの
元気で明るく活発に生きるために忘れてはいけない事実なんです
世の中の哲学はそれを忘れようとしているんです
だから 仏教はちょっと凶暴で忘れるなよと
忘れたらバカになるんだよと
バカになってはいいんだけど
不幸になるんだからね
ですから 忘れてはいけませんと
それで当然なことに この自我が良くない
当たり前でしょ 自我っていうのは自分の意見を通ってほしいと思ったんだから
だから 1日も生きていられません
一つも自分の希望通りにいかなくなっちゃいますから
自我がない人にとっては
もう何でもうまくいきますし
あまり欲張ってはいけないとかね
欲張るということはまるっきり主観でしょうに
そうすると心が硬くなるんです
自分の欲で これやりたい
これやりたいだけで 周りの条件
原因見えなくなっちゃうんです
それから怒るなよと 怒ったら心がピシッと硬くなっちゃうんです
石になっちゃうんです
もう何も調整効かないんです
人生はもうずっと調整だから
石頭ではもう終わり
ですから 欲 わがまま 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみとか そういうものが入っちゃうと
もう周り見えなくなっちゃって
頭が硬く石になっちゃうんです
それでもう はっきりと不幸なんです
永久的に 調整 調整で人生はもう運転するんだぞ ということはなくなっちゃうんです
ですから仏教では 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 欲などというのはね
1500の煩悩がね 良くないと言っているのは
これは幸福のために
そんなものを私から見れば当たり前の話で
怒ってみてください 何がうまくいくんでしょうかと
たとえ人が悪いことをしたとしても
怒らないで落ち着いて見てみてください
うまくいきますから この失敗は損にならないようにすることはできますから
怒ったら 失敗の上に損にもなりますから
ですから ありとあらゆる煩悩っていうのは良くないんだと
煩悩で汚染されちゃうと 必ず不幸になる
体も壊れるか 健康もなくなる
みんなに嫌われる 一つも希望通りにいかない
そもそも希望を作ったことを間違いだしね
だから怒り 欲がある人が
私のこれが希望だとかね
思ったりもするし そういうことだから
このたとえもうどんなことがあっても
穏やかで幸福で楽しく
あ うまくいってるんだという気持ちで生きているためには
そこら辺で柔らかい心が必要なんです
いつでも調整効く心が必要なんですね
それがこのまず人々に対して慈しみが生まれてくると
そうすると自分という主観が消えちゃう
みんな同じという気持ちになっちゃうと
それからやっぱり仏教で言ってる
この善というね 欲が少なく
怒りがなく 嫉妬もなく
清らかな心で生きてみると
すると心が柔らかくなります
すごい柔軟性になります
その場 その場で
その条件に 適応するようになるんですね
だから適応できなくなったら 終わりでしょう
環境に適応できなかったら生きていられないしね
それで人生についてでも
その瞬間 その瞬間に適応できるかないかと
その瞬間に適応できることに智慧というんです
特別にもっと覚えておく知識ではありません
瞬時に現れてくる だったらこうしますということは
だから次どうするべきかという
この問答というかね それを頭の中に入れておくと
いつでも次にどうすればいいかと
まあ智慧が一応出てきますと思います
では 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]